(cris d'effort)
- Des rires d'enfant, les doux
rayons de soleil de fin d'après-
midi, une partie de soccer
improvisée. La vie : pleine,
entière, vraie.
36 enfants :
des orphelins abandonnés,
vulnérables, ont fui les
horreurs et les bombardements.
Ils sont venus en quête de
sécurité relative dans cet
orphelinat de Lviv.  Nina n'a
que 16 ans. Dès le début de
l'invasion, elle a parcouru près
de 1500 km pour r r r r ici,
un voyage de deux jours
organisés par l'orphelinat desùr
fuir sa mère alcoolique.
Nina savoure la tranquillité de
Lviv, mais elle demeure rongée
par l'inquiétude. Sa soeur est
restée à Lysychansk, bombardée
quotidiennement.
Vava aime la nourriture de
l'orphelinat qui lui rappelle
chez lui, il s'ennuie de faire
de la mécanique pour passer le
temps, mais il assssss
nouveaux camarades. Il a été
évacué de Lysychansk, lui aussi,
au début de la guerre.
Il n'a que 16 ans, mais trop
d'expérience pour son âge.C'C'Cs
celle du Donetsk en 2014.
Il se rappelle s'être fait
réveils s s s s s s explosions
dans son jardin.
Sacha parle au téléphone avec
sa maman restée à Zaporijia,
elle l'a envoyé seul, loin
du danger, la semaine dernière
Il n'a que 15 ans, il a fait
le trajet en train en discutant
avec des étrangers, Sacha est
venu à l'orphelinat à piedgagagà
de rentrer à la maison
Selon l'UNICEF, environ 73 000
enfants ukrainiens fuient les
zones de bombardement chaque
jour depuis trois semaines.
Qu'ils soient séparés de leurfae
leurs parents, ils doivent
être protégés.
De nombreuses familles évacuées
arrivent toujours à Lviv, maissé
depuis quelques jours. Après le
chaos aux frontières et
à la gare de Lviv,memememememem.
Ksenia, adolescente de 16 ans
r r r r r r r r réfugiée qui ds
un tiers depuis son arrivée à
Lviv il y a une semaine accueil
les déplacer en cas de sûreté
et de directions.
Sourire, câlin pour ceux qu'elle
reconnaît, une simple présence
rassurante.
"C'est important de leur faire
sentir qu'ils sont chez eux",
dit-elle, on m'a reçue de cettÇe
du stress.
Vienna arrive de Kharkiv où
elle vivait avec ses trois
enfants : Jusslan, Maria et
Ivania. Ils essa
retrouver l'autocar vert
Cracovie en Pologne. Vienna
voulait rester chez elle, mais
les bombardements se sont
dangereusement rapprochés il y a
trois jours.
"Fini, les bruits incessants
d'explosions, même s'il y a
quelques sirènes d'alarme à
Lviv, ce n'est rien comparé à la
peur constante d'être bombardé."
Dans leurs bagages, que
l'essentiel, pas de jouets, mais
beaucoup de vêtements pour les
enfants. Maman s'occupe de tout.
À l'orphelinat, dans cet
environnement sécuritaire,
les enfants osent même penser
à leur avenir.
"Les Russes ne l'emporteront
que s'ils nous tuent tous et ça
n'arrivera jamais", déclare
Sacha.
Dans cette guerre où ils sont
forcés de grandir trop vite, les
enfants arrivent miraculeusement
à conserver un peu de leur
innocence.
Ici Philippe Blanc,
Radio-Canada, Lviv en Ukrai